you know I started this whole project by
looking at it OkCupid and the data and
writing the blog that that I did and
hopefully will one day do again very
soon and it's the best data set in the
world because it's people all strangers
all making judgments of one another all
probably trying to sleep with each other
which is also adds a certain pick one
see to the whole thing so you know you
you look at the data and you really get
a kind of special window and a people
psyche it got me kind of like you could
see everything that was going on in a
big bar on a Friday night and you know
you see that that men are the kind of
pursuers and relationships at a four to
one ratio and it kind of correspondingly
you know women because they're getting
four messages to everyone they send out
like they respond a lot less in response
race to track directly with how hot the
writer was is but then you also see that
once people start talking and they
establish a rapport which for OkCupid is
for converse support for messages going
back and forth the attractiveness kind
of goes out the window at that point
your personality takes over after the
fourth message you see that in general
women's opinions of men's looks like and
you know I get and on average is about
half of what men's opinions of women's
looks are so they kind of get a 50%
discount just ice cold on tinder is
actually a lot more it's something like
a 10 to 10 percent discount or 90%
discount sorry the other way they go at
10 so these environments I think this is
I can't prove this my intuition is that
the more sexual an environment the
larger that discount from from men to
women are from women to men
okay keep his user base in theory on
paper is as liberal as you could ever
want it to be you know you ask people if
they're a Democrat if they're
progressive yes yes yes you know 2 3 2 1
we're all highly coastal very little red
state very blue and a piece of paper
okay keep it should be a very
progressive place and maybe it is
because who knows what the rest of the
world is like but the data that we have
you know black users get three-quarters
of the the messages that the positive
votes they're attractive ratings are
three-quarters of average white user or
or Latino use
for that matter they can reply to about
3/4 of the time is pretty blanket asian
men also get it's a similar discount but
not asian women and then you go and you
look at date hookup which is the site we
run you look at the data from match.com
you see the exact same patterns maybe
not in the exact same ratios but the
same basic up-down yes no pattern when
you compare any race with another race
and it's so it's suggested it's kind of
a once a universal in the sense of
permanent pattern but it's certainly
like a state of affairs right now in the
American psyche I mean these three those
three sites alone you know that they
registered maybe thirty million people
in the United States last year so it's
not like some small sample I mean that's
about half of the single and looking
people in a country to my best guess to
they if you look at the census numbers
so you know it's it's it's pretty
meaningful and pretty depressing thing
to kind of digest you know insofar as
like Grindr or any of these other sites
that kind of hookup apps are hookup apps
for gay men OkCupid is a little bit more
of the relationship site and we have a
very strong gay user base men at male
and female and you know so we get to
look at their patterns and you know
they're basically the same as straight
patterns you know which i think is
meaningful in the context of you know
marriage equality because it certainly
the pre marriage relationships seem
about the same when you actually go and
look at the data which i think is you
know a strong argument for any type of
relationship being held apart legally
for sure right i think the most
significant thing that people do on
OkCupid because it's a precursor to
going out going home with somebody
getting into a relationship with
somebody getting married any of that
stuff it's just messaging right and we
found some kind of crazy stuff like it
doesn't really matter how long your
message is you know the best messages
are very short to 40 to 50 characters
but by best you know they're they get a
reply to 21 22 percent of the time and
kind of all messages get a reply maybe
19 20 percent of the time so it's not
like a massive increase it does help you
to spend a little bit more time on your
message we put a little script to just
track the time since the you know
composition window opened and so if you
put a little bit more effort into your
messages per character it will yield
slightly better results but again you
know it's it's
it's not a huge effect so we were we
were surprised at both of those things I
thought that longer message is we either
do super badly or do super well and it
if you spend a lot of time at least on
your message it would do better than
something you just like and type and go
you know as a writer it's a little sad
to say but it kind of comes down to just
think it doesn't person there's so much
like first impression which online is
your picture frankly you know that your
actual words aren't as relevant as you
probably wish they were so to that point
you know people being the kind of like
intuitive to people in math being the
intuitive geniuses that they are there
was some of the crowds or whatever you
know you have like 20% of messages from
guys to women are copy pasted from other
messages that the guys have sent they
just they found something that for
whatever reason either works or typifies
them or that they liked or whatever it
is and I just just blast it out you know
and those actually they do worse they do
but not that much worse they do like
seventy seventy-five percent of a normal
message a theoretically unique message
and so you get you it's very easy to
arrive at the results per unit effort is
like sky-high just cut and pasting right
and so that probably always something
that increases over time and we don't we
thought about trying to kind of it's
very easy for us to know whether a
message has been cut and pasted from
another message obviously right you just
compare it but we just decided to let
those things go because you know it's
it's it's just the online equivalent of
people having their favorite anecdote
about themselves or this one time they
got into this crazy bar fight or I don't
know some dumb store how I got the scar
that kind of thing in a bar or just like
a standard pickup line that you might
use so it's one of these things that on
the online version of it seems very
weird and kind of unsavory to be like
how this dude just sent the same message
to like 40 people but I probably told
the same story everybody that I am
friends with has probably heard a large
set of the same stories for me you know
and it's something that people just do
you